one option if we hate our jobs obviously
is to leave it but if we actually cannot
leave our job for various reasons the
question is what are we supposed to do
be the leader you wish you had working
at a hard job working for a bad boss can
sometimes be one of the greatest
education 'z ever so the question is can
can you change your mindset instead of
waking up in the morning going oh I
can't do this again
but rather buted University you know
you're getting a master's degree in
leadership and you may be learning
everything how not to do things and you
to wake up and be like what am I gonna
learn today
early on in my career I had it I had a
really bad boss who believed that she
could get the most out of us by berating
us and and she told me once that I had
one of my reviews and she said you have
no talent and I was like nothing and she
was like nothing this was her way of I
guess motivating me but I had such a
good attitude about it for a couple of
reasons one because I knew I think knew
what I was up against every day and
instead of taking it personally I viewed
it as as my education of how not to lead
and I literally would file this stuff
all the way and use it some day I get to
use it now and also misery loves company
you know I had fantastic a fantastic
relationship with my team we looked
after each other because we all had this
the suppressive bus we would compare the
advice that we got in our in our in our
little career building sessions and and
we took care of each other and so we had
a responsibility to each other and
that's where we cut our teeth on being
leaders and it actually made the job
wonderful yes there were days they were
oppressive yes there were days that I
hated yes there are days I want to like
pull my hair out and just quit but it's
because of the team that I had and we
looked after each other and the mindset
of learning every day that I that I made
the most of it so I think mindset is a
huge huge huge part of actually getting
some joy out of a difficult job
[Music]